kind of an embarrassing week for Fox
News analyst britt hume you may have
heard about this britt hume posted a
screengrab on twitter about the election
and it showed an open tab on Brit Humes
web browser that said sexy vixen vinyl
yes this is real Brit Hume was clearly
on that website and clearly forgot to
close it off before posting his picture
really embarrassing did you see that
Andy I did and I actually looked up the
sexy vixen vinyl page and this is what
Brit Hume was looking at I'm he's
looking at that like that skeevy get up
in the middle of the day can you believe
it
wait a minute Andy I'm sorry was that a
screenshot from your computer yeah okay
we just saw your open browser tabs just
now so Andy they're filthy Billy put the
shot up again look at that you've got
ESPN but then you've got young and hung
failure but and backdoor [ __ ]
any what the hell is wrong with you what
the hell is wrong with you Conan nilly
click on young and hung see it's a law
firm Conan I'm having a property dispute
with my neighbor and they are highly
recommended what were you talking about
all right all right all right you could
see how I was misled though hey what
about Phil you're but what about that
one
well the table got cut off show the page
see Phil your butter dispenser for my
popcorn machine
I lost the instructions ok I'm sorry
Andy
and I'm guessing back door [ __ ] is a
news story about a guy who built a pet
door in the back of his house for his
prized rooster that's exactly what it
was
I don't know what to say Andy
well how about I'm sorry okay well hey
what about ESPN Sports Andy you're not
really into sports
Billy click on ESPN
I go to a lot of fancy events you didn't
see that anything coming did ya
you